welcome to today it is nice to have you
with us and Hoda it is nice to have you
right back where you belong Hoda Kotb
makes an emotional return to the Today
Show revealing her daughter has been in
the ICU I'm grateful to my family and
I'm grateful to friends like you who
were there every single day on Monday
the journalist appeared on the NBC
morning show for the first time in two
weeks filling viewers in on the personal
matter that's kept her off the air my
youngest hope
um was in the ICU for a few days in the
hospital for a little more than a week
I'm so grateful she's home she is back
home I was waiting for that day to come
and we are watching her closely I'm just
so happy Hoda's last live appearance on
the show was February 17th yay for
Friday and yay for this long holiday
weekend it's arriving right on time Tom
yamas and today third hour co-host Craig
Melvin subbed in for Hoda alongside
Savannah Guthrie while Willie Geist from
Sunday today and Chanel Jones of today
third hour filled in alongside Jenna
Bush Hager for Hoda's fourth hour gig
Chanel is here for Hoda Willie Geist is
in for Hoda last week Craig and Chanel
manned the desk at the top of the show
while Savannah was out with covid and
gave you her some insight into Hoda's
absence we know a lot of you have been
wondering how she's doing we can tell
you that Hoda's okay she's got a family
health matter that she has been dealing
with so we look forward to seeing Hoda
and Savannah back here at the desk very
very soon well both Hoda and Savannah
returned Monday and Hoda says she's
feeling the love when your child is ill
the amount of gratitude you can have for
for people for who helped you out so
um I'm grateful for the doctors at Wild
Cornell who were amazing and the nurses
and I'm grateful to my family and I'm
grateful to friends like you who were
there every single day so I want to say
thank you for that I really I love you I
love you too Oda didn't elaborate on the
reason for her daughter's
hospitalization but on Monday she did
share this message of Hope on Instagram
writing anything's possible the today
anchor shares two children with her ex
Joel schiffman six-year-old Haley and
three-year-old hope the former couple
adopted Haley in 2017 after Hoda's 2007
battle with breast cancer left her
unable to conceive I always had this
thing inside me that just like it was a
voice I couldn't quiet
it was a voice that wanted to be a mom
but thought it was too late it was that
voice and I think you know you can push
a voice like that away for a long time
but sooner or later it comes back up
and you have to address it then two
years later Hoda and Joel adopted hope
it is something that um is important to
to me and to to Joel to us really
because we like the idea of of Haley not
um we want her to have a sibling because
she has such interesting circumstances
to grow up in any way so it would be
nice to be able to share it with
somebody Hoda and Joel announced their
split last year and at the time Jenna
praised her friend for her Grace Under
Pressure I'm proud of Hoda every single
day she is filled with compassion and
Grace and she does everything that way I
mean I watch her come into the office
every morning smiling and every single
person she's treated me with such love
and been a mentor and now I'm a really
dear friend so it's no surprise she does
everything in life with Grace and
compassion
[Music]
thank you